l'ensemble de mes concerts suite à un
problème de santé en effet on vient de
me dire dynastique est une tumeur au
poumon
tumeur cancéreuse pas très sympathique
qui ne peut pas s'opérer donc je dois
rentrer dans un protocole de six mois de
chimiothérapie et de rayons x vous savez
tous que dans la vie le plus important
c'est la santé et quand on a un problème
il devient prioritaire moi et ma moitié
devons
nous mettre en mode guerrier afin
d'affronter cette cette épreuve un peu
particulier à dire si je suis pour ou
contre c'est très personnel pardon
parler pas mal de sujets non voilà les
people doivent-elles oui ou non
communiquée sur la maladie il ya pas mal
de huy a deux noms et puis il ya ne se
prononce pas ah bah oui enfin je crois
pourquoi je donnerai mon avis sur
quelque chose d'aussi personnel que la
maladie voilà qu'un est ce que ça te
choque que quoi qu'ils en parlent ouais
ah non je trouve ça je trouve donc tv
nantes mais si l'on parlait pas je le
jugerais pas non mais c'est pas la
question si vous parlez pas je le
jugerais pas d'accord ils compliquent
tout de suite à la non mais c'est vrai
que je peux lâcher du désolé mais c'est
difficile d'avoir un avis tu râles j'ai
commencé par un nom était un jean-michel
pourquoi est ce que ça te ou non parce
que je suis peut-être d'une ancienne
époque et pour moi c'est tout ça relève
de l'intimité
[Rires]
des choses mais maintenant je mets pas
tout qu'est-ce qu'ils ne sais pas ce
n'est pas mon père par exemple les
parties d'un cancer mais la mange j'en
ai souffert qu'eux mêmes comme comme
beaucoup de gens aient enfin de la perte
de mon père et il me l'a même jamais dit
non qu'il n'aime pas dit à moi donc
j'imagine même pas que quelqu'un puisse
se dire à françois tiers moi je le
savais mais son cancer je savais donc du
quartier donc et donc non je trouve ces
quelques mots sur quatre et un français
sur quatre concerts ou qu'il a et c je
me retape pour des gens voire dé jean
pierre pernaut des florent pagny dire
simplement voilà je traverse une maladie
un tu te dis ça n'arrive pas qu'à mon
sens les
deux tu vas aller suivre aussi peut-être
qu'ils vont s'en sortir je
m'avançais croisette on est sortis à
plein de mecs ont des cancers de la
prostate tu es content de voir le patron
du trésor te dire et courage notre truc
aussi c'est de dire arrêter de fumer ce
qui avait fait perdre aux d'ailleurs
bien sûr est à qu'à un moment donné
cancer du poumon concert du poumon par
dont deux par jour en janvier j'essaye
cubes en quinze ans il fumait comme
orange et à leurs enfants que j'ai pas
eu besoin de jean pierre pernaut pour
savoir qui fait débat
besoin de voir les fumées les bords faut
manger sainement c'est la honte d'avoir
le cancer pour certains dans son boulot
ne pas voir le dire tout simplement dans
son boulot sur un cancer du poumon
coquille année c'est la première qu un
cancer chez les hommes 1 le même et
florian aussi un enfant j'entendais oui
mais vous savez ça me rappelait toujours
ses clés vous vous déplacez pour que ce
soit dans la presse people pas du tout
justement juste une chose c'est
important ouais on dira que les people
très souvent s'en prennent aux journaux
people parce qu'on parle de leur vie
privée mais où est la limite à quel
moment où eux se disent là j'en parle
mais par contre rideau sur tout le reste
je pense que
c'est comme le
concept et célébrités elles ont un rôle
d'influenceurs c'est pas juste des gens
qu'on va voir au spectacle ou cinémas
ont atteint la finale et n'a jamais non
mais je continue parce que c'est très
important c'est à dire que ces gens là
décide à tel moment je communique je
communique pas on n'est pas idiot on
sait très bien comment ça fonctionne ils
ont un public il ya des sous en jeu il
ya des assurances derrière ne communique
pas tout le temps que quand il faut il
compte il communique quand ils ont envie
évidemment florent pagny là c'est tout à
fait normal qu'il en parle parce qu'il a
toute une série de concerts donc il doit
bien à son public la vérité est obligé
de donner autant de détails mais il
était arrêté aurait dit que vous dites
qu'elle nous dit que les people ne
peuvent pas choisir sur cette oeuvre
d'art c'est parce que je dis non non
c'est pas que j'aime n'ont fait je dis
juste qu'il y a des limites dans la dent
dans l'impudeur c'est vous qui allez
il ya des limites
seront bannis
jeudi c'est bon je leur fais chanter
vous gagnez de l'argent aujourd'hui en
étant journaliste parce que vous parlez
de la vie privée des people mais pas que
deux des trois grands partis de quel
droit elles n'ont pas le vois pas je
leur dis que je n'avais pas le droit
j'ai juste dit
gérard de communication c'est tout et
qu' il faut que ça est
d'accord elle dans la mesure où on n'est
pas idéaux on n'a pas besoin d'eux pour
savoir qu'on peut attraper le cancer
jouit pas du tout d'accord il fallait
bien faite à l'iran normaux mais c'est
des humains on a besoin de ça pour
savoir que c'est à
dire guillaume questionnement laetitia
milot a parlé de l'endométriose rs6
avant d'en parler grâce à ça la loi a
été votée la semaine dernière on parle
du bassin du 100 nage au lycée faire
enlever les deux seins grâce à ça ça
rassure et des femmes se sont dits
angélina je le fais j'étais je peux moi
aussi en parler je peux le faire et puis
une dernière chose ares vous oubliez est
ce que vous croyez qu'un mec comme
florent pagny qui dit tout qui est cash
qu'est le mec le plus sûr du fnla comme
elle a besoin de public sous ces photos
qui sont répugnantes pour pour aller
annoncer qu'il a un cancer vous comptez
où tu sais pas si ça d'autant qu'il
s'est passé ce lycée c'est énorme il ya
un moment dès 6 heures ne sont pas des
folies quelques faux pas des hommes
politiques j'espère pour toi que tu n'as
pas été extrêmement malade ça m'est
arrivé l'année dernière j'ai eu un truc
épouvantable
on m'a opéré deux fois pendant des
heures sur une table d'opération c'était
très grave ça n'était pas loin de ce
qu'avait ce monsieur est battu c'est
quoi dans la chambre d'à côté il y avait
un monsieur qui était seul j'avais la
même chose que moi et le fait que les
stars dix mois j'ai ça le type d'à côté
il m'a dit il en a chialé en disant
[ __ ] je suis pas tout seul j'ai
quelqu'un khimki qui m'aident parce que
quand tu affrontes ce genre de maladie
la seule chose qui compte c'est ton
mental clair c'est
la messe est touchant c'est tout ça
parce que je ne savais pas que je ne
savais pas que guillaume en parlerait
comme voilà comme c'est mon associé mon
ami qu'on a traversé ensemble année
dernière et c'était difficile ouais donc
donc tout d'un coup faciale et non mais
c'est pas qu'ils s'immiscent du coup
sebok excuser parce que je rasais bas
qu'il en parlerait en principe on a une
famille on a des proches des amis qui me
suis
dit oh pardon elle n'écoute pas ce qu'on
dit peter le truc vertueux c'est que
juste des gens qui sont malades chez eux
qui sont pas star entendre des gens
connus pour du fric hakim pour qui tout
va bien en parler très normalement donc
y'a plus compter ses infâmes infamant il
ya un saut terrible sur ta gueule parce
que tu es cancéreux c'est ça il ya juste
des gens qu'on parle des gens voilà donc
le message de laurent il est bien
d'espoir c'est plein d'espoir c'est
positif on on sent qu'il a envie de se
battre qui va être fort et ça non quand
même tu sens qu'il est bien installé
dans ta bille oui mais il n'est pas
c'est
utile et surtout surtout et surtout le
goût moi ce que j'aimerais dire comme
jean misait sur les potes mais tu as
pris conscience je porte souvent le côté
le nombre de personnes qui sont seules
chez elles n'avaient pas toutes les
marines en sixième qui sont en province
qui sont en banlieue qui sont seules
chez elles et qui n'ont pas de famille
qui n'ont plus d'amis qu'ils sont quand
tu es seul comme ça je pense que ton
seul recours c'est peut-être
effectivement d'avoir des gens qui te
dit tu vois un mec comme père noël que
des gens star et j'en sais pas car il
vend pas mais j'ai pas besoin d'une star
spécialement quand toi mais tout le
monde n'est pas venu mais elle n'a pas
des anonymes [ __ ] tu as elle va pas
faire une vidéo qui va faire des
millions de vues comme celle de florent
galore j'aimerais avoir la vida primer
avant une question parce qu'il ya pas
mal de stars aussi qui ne communiquent
pas dessus guillaume durand n'a rien dit
il a eu un cancer puis l'a dit après
clémentine célarié nos célarié pardon
n'a rien dit non plus jova l'ena qui
n'en parle même notoriété que que
florent pagny fait alors une autre
question moi ya beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont dit c'est vrai qu'ils voyaient par
exemple une femme comme françoise hardy
ça va faire trois ou quatre ans qu'elle
fait toutes les émissions de laurent
ruquier et casse afin qu'ils y va cg ça
j'ai mal là et j'ai des fuites de machin
à djenane acquise c'est indécent
d'écouter ça c'était une énorme star l'a
fait rêver tous les mecs à savoir alors
c'est non mais il y en a qui disent est
ce que ça vous ne comprenez vous pas que
les plaintes un peu d'aidé people qui
viennent sur les plateaux pour parler de
leur maladie y en a qui trouve ça
indécent est ce qu'on peut entendre ça
aussi c'est ce que je crois en ce sens
c'est ce que je pense norme et non alors
l'une est visé c'est florian malheureux
ton jugement ton jugement il est
influencé par ton travail du tout mais
bien sûr que oui parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on vient gratter un
petit peu dans dans ton assiette parce
que si les pipoles balance tout leur
scoop tu auras plus rien derrière
florian je te rappelle que delarue
delarue apparaît fils conférence de
presse parce qu'à un journaliste avait
piqué son dossier elle met dans voici
mais oui oui mais alors mais on peut
prendre des exemples isolés et raconter
son histoire c'est ce que tu viens de
faire maintenant moi je pense pas ça je
peux pas je parle juste de pudeur je dis
juste que il ya des gens et je suis
d'accord avec jean michel qui ne sont
pas forcément enchanté ou qui se sentent
pas forcément soutenu parce que des
personnalités vont donner leur exemple
déjà aussi parce qu'ils sont très seuls
et qu'ils savent aussi que ces
personnalités la honte un soutien
médiatique moral et même médical
peut-être bien plus puissants que leurs
dons mais n'en veut si si si il n'y a
pas que j'aie jamais entendu parler a
dit j'avais entendu quelqu'un me dire
sur quand je suis de corvette closer
droite est obligé de lâcher certains
gars vous dire comme c'est
qu'effectivement ce qui est vrai aussi
c'est que dans le cadre de la rue c'est
vrai on avait piqué son dossier du coup
il a fait une conférence de presse à
france télévisions pour le dire faire
l'annoncé mois dans le baba de dollars
eu
ah bah merci pour coup on a la vidéo de
dollars eu effectivement qui ont parlé
regardé c'était il ya dix ans je crois
je suis le 15 ou 16 novembre dernier à
l'hôpital j'avais très mal au ventre le
vent se gonfler on m'a retiré le cas
litres d'eau dans le ventre
on s'occupait de moi je sens est rentré
directement
à la maison soit géré et on a 200
lendemain
et j'aimerais qu'on me garder et j'ai
compris on veut très vite puisqu'il est
né s'en était
parfait
et les infirmes bien aussi que
que j'avais un cancer jeu je dis que
tout le monde veut allez savoir donc
autant que sur moi qui le disent
maintenant qu'ils changent de pose
aujourd'hui c'est si j'avais eu le choix
de le dire ou de ne pas lutter à ce que
je leur ai dit est ce que j'aurais eu
assez de courage
je ne sais pas mais les choses sont
comme ça excellente vidéo merci beaucoup
de très bons choix d'avoir une soirée
effectivement il l'a dit parce que la
presse qu'israël allait sortir est ce
qu'il aurait dit ou pas face à mathieu
là la question la ctf qu'elles ont
raison d'en parler oui mais aussi si
elles ne veulent pas le faire c'est leur
droit
oui mais non et et à en parler en
revanche oui ils ont raison de le faire
sien le alors sachez quand même que dans
le cas de florian pardon de florent
pagny
pas là on a appelé des gens qu'on
connaît avec guillaume c'est vrai et
qu'en l'occurrence florent pagny ne l'a
pas fait du tout parce qu'il pensait
qu'elle est certaine la presse people
ils s'en foutent et leurs yeux alors ils
sont fous du dollar et la femme est pour
chris court circuiter dieu voulait
préciser une chose importante parce que
là et ça c'est très important je sais
que cette caricature sur la presse
people et qui existe et c'est normal
c'est très très rare que la presse
people sortent des maladies de
célébrités c'est rarissime ah oui prenez
la liste et mettez là on la procession
public et closer
c'est parce que là c'est parce que ça
montrait trop cher ou séparés tic les
titres
jurisprudence qui laisse croire à des
animaux faisant appel alors pour sa
flore saison face à metz que ça serait
trop chère
non mais vous vouliez ou non déontologie
moralité
alors j'adore me rem palombes enfin 200
tpm peine zackham sorti la taille de la
tumeur le machin ou à les placer j'adore
me parler une fois que ces tunnels à 10
ans l'information à la rédaction après
la sortie quand même là j'étais mal
assortis oui mais mathieu après appris
durant la période après que florian pas
de florent pagny pardon en ai parlé
est-ce que vous posez une question qui
va voilà non pas qui fâchent mais juste
qui vous fait quoi ce soir
évidemment je vous souhaite le meilleur
à tous et bien sûr et c'est un sujet dur
mais voilà vous comme vous vous êtes
très copieux laurent est extrêmement
connu et tout vous commencez à l'être
vous l'être vous l'êtes pardon si vous
aviez de maladies aussi graves est ce
que oui le nouveau communiqué rio ax
éléments genre si tu me pose la question
on doit absolument jamais sur la brèche
à côté un peu solitaire un peu sangliers
dont j'ai plutôt tendance à me renfermer
sur moi même mais absolument jamais
parce que je veux pas qu'ils salt hélas
très funky son fils à mes enfants ma
famille pour april très quoi moi je
pense que oui parce que mons et j'ai le
courage de le faire je le ferai et puis
de toute façon je pense que les gens se
rendrait compte sur les réseaux sociaux
que y'a un truc qui va pas de garçons
courage que ce soit et un point à signer
ces deux là lâche 6 malvy enfin non
sélection de choix c'est une question de
choix semaine cascada mais sais tu sais
quoi je n'ai pas la réponse moi donc ça
m'intéresse guillaume mais j'en sais
rien c'est hyper personnel ça dépend du
moment ça dépend de l'état ça dépend des
fins à de l'agencé n'attend ludivine
merci à toi oui moi je pense que c'est
salutaire mais on voit chez florent
pagny c'est une leçon une leçon d'amour
une leçon d'honnêteté c'est une lotion
d'une leçon civisme aussi pour aider les
autres moi je le dirai évidemment
laurent
on rappelle que les gens incinéré ou
enterré je sais pas répondre à cette
question c'est horrible je le joue
d'avoir vous dites
touche du bois je n'arriverais avec des
gens sérieux
poser question honnêtement et que je
sais que ça peut servir une à son pays
des gens devraient coûter tous peut-être
et vous
hugo toujours tout beau me frappe dans
la perspective de potentiellement aider
les autres même si c'est que quelques
personnes qui vont sortir touché soutenu
ou qui vont avoir l'impression de
revivre la même chose que moi et donc de
ne pas être seul comme on le disait tout
à l'heure
rien que pour ça ça vaut le coup de le
faire mais d'akon à moi j'ai un peu peur
de la pitié des gens je pense que ça
elle annonce oui mais aussi pour dire la
vie vous voyez sur les réseaux sociaux
ce que moi je communique réseau mais en
fait tout va bien tout est joyeux on
rigole on pleure jamais banon il ya
aussi des choses tristes et des
événements ingrat qui arrive bien sens
car oui love pardon ça dépend aussi
quittait jean michel maire annonce qu'il
va cancer de la prostate je pense que
c'est plus compliqué pour lui pardon
jean-michel de le dire mais je vais lire
à puma
mais vous côté lover que tu as et où il
ya des trucs qui sont plus où tu ne
penses pas que yann jeu mais bien sûr
nommé le choix mais la méthode à la
battle over j'ai pas médecin mais
ouais ouais c'est tout ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'à un moment donné il ya
des maladies qui sont plus gênante que
l'autre difficile wii minna mais bien
sûr bien sûr et je rappelle qu'à
l'époque pardon mais alors que des mâles
maintenant mais je rappelle par exemple
tiré le bureau est parti d'une maladie
enfin on est on le sait c'est sorti
vingt ans après j'imagine que la réponse
est non vous déjà fort que que je
devienne célèbre d'abord
commencé et puis je rejoins jean michel
non hors de question ça regarde que moi
et ma famille est très bien et moi alors
c'est encore plus difficile un truc moi
honnêtement je crois que c'est horrible
je crois que je ne dirais pas et de
compte je me retire elle sera très pas
très marrant paris parce que culture
l'axé mixte du matin je pense que je
partirai un petit peu loin pour une
personne ne voit et tout ça et voilà ces
voix là mais je rappelle quand même que
ça peut très souvent que tout le monde
est en très bonne santé sur wings assaut
sur le public aussi chez vous aussi je
touche du bois pour que tout ça pour ça